H S FACILITIES USED UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BLAMING
EVERYTHING HAPPENING ON THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: LET’S BRING IN DONALD
TRUMP JUNIOR, EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE, DEFENSE OF THE
INDEFENSIBLE.
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS HAS THE JOB
FOR FIVE DAYS IS, QUOTE, IN A
LONG SOUNDBITE IT TAKES TIME TO
BUILD OF THE DEPTH OF CRUELTY
THE ADMINISTRATION BEFORE US
ESTABLISHED.
YOU ARE SEEING THE SYSTEM, THE
TIME THAT IT TAKES TO REBUILD
IT VIRTUALLY FROM SCRATCH.
SINCE THEY TOOK OVER THE WHOLE
BORDER IS BLOWING UP.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
THE POLICY SAYS IF YOU COME
HERE WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU
FREE HEALTH, WE ARE GOING TO DO
THIS, WE HAVE AN OPEN BORDER
POLICY.
THAT IS CREATING A DEMAND.
THAT IS CREATING A FLOOD OF
PEOPLE COMING IN.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE
OVERWHELMED, BECAUSE THEY ARE
TELLING THEM TO COME HERE AND
IF YOU DO WE WILL TAKE CARE OF
YOU FOR LIFE.
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION BUILD A WALL.
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS WERE GOING
DOWN RAPIDLY.
DRUG TRAFFICKING, WERE CUT INTO
A FRACTION OF WHAT THEY USED TO
BE BY THE VESSEL 9 POLICIES OF
BAD PEOPLE USING CHILDREN,
USING WOMEN TO GET INTO AMERICA
TO DO NOT SO GREAT THINGS IN
MANY CASES.
THIS IS INSANITY.
IF WE HAD AN HONEST MEDIA.
IF THEY DIDN’T SUFFER OR GET
AWAY WITH LIBERAL PRIVILEGE, WE
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
REALITY.
IT IS A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
ISSUE.
WHEN YOU GIVE THEM EVERYTHING
THEY COULD POSSIBLY WANT THEY
ARE GOING TO COME AND THAT IS
THE DEGREE OF CRISIS.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE THAT IS THE TITLE OF
YOUR NEW YORK TIMES BESTSELLER.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO WRITE SOME
SORT OF NEW CHAPTER AND YOU
WOULD TITLE THAT I TOLD YOU SO.
EXPLAIN.
>> 100%.
IN THE FIRST 30 DAYS ALONE IF
YOU INCLUDE 35 DAYS I SAID THEY
WOULD BE BOMBING THE MIDDLE
EAST IN A FEW MINUTES TO
SATISFY THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX AND THE DC BUREAUCRATS
THAT WENT TO SIT ON THE BOARD
OF RAY SOIN IN THE STIMULUS
PACKAGE.
NOT SURE WHAT THAT DOES FOR
COVID-19 RELIEF BUT WE WILL
SEND MORE BOMBS TO THE MIDDLE
EAST.
THE REALITY IS EVERYONE KNEW
WHAT THIS RADICAL
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO BUT NO
ONE WOULD SAY, THE MEDIA WENT
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO COVER JOE
BIDEN’S RADICALISM, THE
RADICALISM OF THE PEOPLE WITHIN
HIS AGENDA SO HE WILL NOT END
FRACKING, YOU SEE IS, HE SAID
IT 100 TIMES.
I LITERALLY PICKED EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF THESE THINGS,
WHETHER IT IS ENERGY, NO
PROBLEM WITH RUSSIA HAVING A
PIPELINE.
THAT IS FINE BUT AN AMERICAN
PIPELINE TO MAKE OUR GAS PRICES
CHEAPER, TO CREATE JOBS, WE
CAN’T POSSIBLY HAVE THAT.
SAME WITH IMMIGRATION, AMNESTY,
FREE HEALTHCARE, FREE
EDUCATION, THAT WILL NOT CREATE
A SWAY TO THE BORDER, DROP
PEOPLE TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
FOR THEM, YOU CAN FLOOD THOSE
SYSTEMS, GET MUCH LESS BENEFIT
FROM ALL OF IT.
IN LIBERAL PRIVILEGE.
AND AND YOU SEE WHAT THEY’VE
DONE TO CONSERVATIVE
PUBLISHERS.
GO TO DONJUNIOR.COM.
NO ONE IN MEDIA, NO REPORTERS
OR JOURNALISTS WERE WILLING TO
LOOK AT THE FACTS AND REPORT
THEM BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT
WOULD HURT JOE BIDEN AND THEIR
ULTIMATE GOAL OF PUTTING
DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE.
AINSLEY: YOU ARE CRITICIZED FOR
THE PICTURE WITH GUNS BEHIND
YOU AND SO WITH SOME OTHER
LAWMAKERS AND CANCEL CULTURE
TRYING TO CANCEL DR. SEUSS NOW.
HOW FAR ARE THEY GOING TO TAKE
THIS?
>> THERE IS NO PLACE THEY WON’T
GO, NO PLACE THEY WON’T GO.
THIS WEEK ALONE THEY CANCELED
MISTER POTATO HEAD.
THE MUPPETS.
THEY ARE CANCELING DR. SEUSS
FROM READING PROGRAMS.
I KNOW THE CAT IN THE HAT
WITHOUT THE BOOK I HAVE READ IT
SO MANY TIMES TO MY CHILDREN.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT RACIST.
YOU HAVE OREO COOKIE CHIMING IN
ON TRENDS RIGHTS.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
IT IS INSANE.
WE’VE LOST OUR MINDS AND WE ARE
ENCOURAGING IT BY NOT ALLOWING
IT, GOING AFTER CPAC, THE
STAGE, THESE GUYS ARE SO
OBSESSED WITH TRYING TO CREATE
ANY LINK TO THAT AND LOOK LIKE
HYATT WAS DOING A GOOD JOB.
THEY CAME TO THE WOKE MOB.